ah chin up you okay let's go kevin
i'm concussed right now keep your hand
there give me this leg first and then
slide down in there like a cockpit
let's go let's make this a great one
let's go cows
[Music]
oh come on
chad just stalled
on the pit
that's all right buddy do it again first
gear
just get on the gap
all right i know we're gonna join this
dictionary this is embarrassing 85
he got the second gear he got the second
gear take that position five feet above
the yellow multiple times during the
time trial bring the rpms up to 4 000.
you're gonna have a conversation with
the creator and the creator told me he's
like you got this
come on gabby you got left
greg's going to be the guy to beat
getting that little group five feet
about the yellow line and you stay there
focus your vision ahead
bob what i need you to do is i need you
to just lie to my to my friends
speed racer what you think that was
[ __ ] great
there's no question i got the highest
speed by far you guys are looking at a
champion bro
here are the results 1500 bucks this is
revealing an order of slowest the
fastest okay so this this racer is not
on the podium for fastest speed
that's me
i knew you didn't go fast i went the
slowest
top speed
159 miles per hour this is some bull
in third place kelly stewart
159.96 almost 160 miles an hour that
means i've chat went over 160. right now
we just found somebody you know we
greg ivory was the second fastest driver
i'm gonna pull up talladega nice right
now and strip and run down this track
listen i can't believe these results
what and what the top speed in beth's
friends chad ocho cinco johnson 164 wow
point eight five eighty five foot
six eighty five no way that's rigged i
like to thank my colleagues for trying
but now they know what it feels like
when people try to cover me on sundays
no matter how much you practice no
matter how much film you watch
the end result was the same you lost and
that's what happened here today so kyle
busch get your brother kirk come see me
denny hamlin
bubba wallace i know you ride for jordan
but come see me i'll hold you out
it's rigged
i won